everybody that's never questioned the
realness of Kane and the fans and all of
that it's kind of like you can't fake
selling up the Staples Center in 90
minutes Dean Brown is sharing his rise
to country music stardom in a brand new
Amazon music mini documentary velocity
the heav'n singer along with his wife
Caitlin and members of the team are
giving fans a behind-the-scenes glimpse
into his life on and off the stage from
his early Facebook videos of cover songs
to a sold-out concert at the Staples
Center we're breaking down everything we
learned about the Tennessee born star I
owned a barber shop back in the day and
Chattanooga Tennessee he came in one day
and he showed me a video I was just
messing around I don't even think that I
was you know trying to get a career out
of it I was you know working two jobs
just trying to afford my truck and uh
playing xbox when I got bored I would
you know just sing covers and put them
on Facebook and Instagram just hoping to
get followers never thinking you know a
record label would hit me up or anything
now being a country music star may not
have always been the plan for Kane who
was just trying to afford its truck but
after a few cover videos quickly went
viral he never looked back and so he
breaks on Facebook people start
discovering him they're all sharing him
his I remember he was growing by like
20,000 social media followers a day or
something like it was just insane we the
first show we did in Darlington South
Carolina he was the 725 cap room I'll
never forget it we put it on sale and it
sold out in like 20 minutes after the
shows Cain would stay and me every
single person and take a picture with
every single person and he was so
grateful for each person that was there
because he knew that those people being
there is what's making his career
there's no doubt Cain's natural stage
presence and connection with his fans
contributed to his rise to the top but
it also could have been his early
fashion choices which he has some choice
words about now
at the early lot of performances at a
time I thought were sick and amazing and
then I'd go back and look at it what was
that wearing like I was wearing these
like plaid shorts leave button-up so it
just bothers looked good and I guess I
know it was awful though with eight
number one hits and multiple CMT and
American Music Awards the singer sure
has a lot to celebrate professionally
but nothing tops the birth of his baby
girl
Kingsley Rose you know I got my backbone
my daughter and my wife and I know that
I'll always be there I feel a little
more grown-up stuff liked a little kid
but I still feel I couldn't grown up now
like I'm a dad he's there every day
every night when I was pregnant he never
missed the doctor's appointment I see a
new twinkle in bro now straight up like
when it comes to Kingsley like I've seen
his voice change and his eyes light up
and she's the sweetest little thing ever
now that Kingsley is born it's crazy I
like cane was born to be a dad and you
can just see it after growing up without
a father of his own Cain is committed to
being the best he can be for his little
girl which he sings about in his
emotional new ballad for my daughter
just being a dad that's always there I
think that's a that'll be a huge part of
her life and I can give her anything she
want so I don't know she just she's
Malin she's my life now Kane became only
the 11th country artist to sell out the
Staples Center but it was an emotional
ride to get there the singer had to
unexpectedly postpone the show's
original date after the shocking death
of his longtime drummer Kenny Dixon who
died in a car accident on his way home
from tour takes a big toll
because everybody's family something
like that happened it just tore em apart
Kane and those guys are brothers and
this is everything to them I feel like
all of us are really feeling like we're
doing this not only just for for Kane
and like for for the career and for
everything but we're all doing it for
Kenny like for our own hearts every show
going forward Kenny will be in in our
minds
they're taking time to mourn the death
of his friend and bandmate Kane made his
Staples Center debut on January 9 my
whole family
like they get to share this moment with
me playing staples everybody at people
who work to me that helped me get here
I've been wanting to be here and them
they're just you know family since day
one it's just amazing so that is so
incredible to think about just from
where he started
Kane is playing this and he not only is
playing a big sold it out in 90 minutes
it's a pinnacle of where he's come from
but a start to where he's going and I
love that because instead of it being
the close of something I feel like it's
this wonderful beautiful fresh start
that we all need it's exciting so
there's no doubt Kane Browns career is
only going up from here but what did you
think of velocity what was your favorite
moment let us know in the comments below